oh oh
I'm gonna hinge the spine
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste I'm Connor featuring your boys
Scott and Joey featuring featuring
features this is a YouTube channel I'm
sorry was this the YouTube
when you host you can feature me and
whoever else it is today it's the Sea
Dog show wow
I I suppose I should have a topic to
talk about yeah well you are the host
well we are the demons in your head so
we'll just uh what do you want to talk
about today we'll just play along
uh long what if what if
no okay
sometimes I go into like God mode in the
shower and I'm like and I have this
existential thought that just [__]
hits me and I'm like okay I'm terrified
of something new now great why are you
terrified of sleeping that because okay
what is the difference many times what
is the difference between sleeping and
dying tell me that tell me that uh wow
you dream when you sleep uh you're not
dead that's the biggest aside from that
but but from your own perspective you
wake back up no there is there's no
difference your brain is like goes I
think I thought about this because I was
like what I always fall into like random
Youtube holes and I was just like random
facts people don't know how anesthesia
he works but it just does for some
reason right what do you mean like in
terms of like you know when you go under
for surgery yeah like they still do not
like know on a molecular level why like
anesthesia works why it knocks you out
yeah but then now I'm afraid to take
anesthesis
well I don't know how
it seems to be weird
so I would just take it if I was you
it'd save my kid yeah because I've
luckily luckily I've never needed like
surgery or anything like that so I've
never needed to go under
um so I don't know I don't know I don't
know what it's like I have any of you
guys needed to take anesthesia or
anything like that I think do I ever go
to the hospital I need to get anything
serious done he's like man we gotta
stitch up your finger man just put me
under just just [__] knock me out
let's I do not want to be work for any
of this yeah I'm totally fine with you
opening me up while I'm asleep I just
don't want to know every time they take
blood from you they just like pull me on
the door
blood's probably like my my like it's
getting closer to my limit of like man I
don't want to do this yeah I'll do it
yeah I I didn't realize before but I
think I just I don't know I don't think
I have a fear of getting my blood taken
but I think I'd like to know when I'm
getting my blood taken beforehand so I
can have you ever had your blood taken
without you knowing no not without my
nails no no
take my blood but uh actually today I
did have an appointment yeah uh and I
did need to get my blood taken and I
didn't know that I needed to get my
blood taken oh you thought you felt
uncomfortable you turned up and yeah oh
you want to know beforehand yeah yeah so
normally we would normally when I go to
the doctor or when we have a health
checkup I'm like okay I'm getting my
blood taken I can mentally prepare
myself I know this is gonna happen so I
go to this appointment and they're like
okay uh we probably need to just do a
quick check of your blood uh before
anything else as well since it's been a
while and I'm like
sorry what wait so how much notice do
you need then how much notice yeah how
much notice I gotta give you before I
take your blood
you gotta you gotta put in like a notice
like just a One Wing thing yeah one day
thing just just when when I turn up to
the building for an appointment you just
want to check up I just want to know
before so I can just be like okay I'm
getting my blood taken today and here's
the thing I don't know why I never used
to think about this I know before I'd be
like getting blood taken whatever but
yeah the more the time has gone on for
some reason I don't know if it is being
around Sydney because Sydney has Sydney
is deathly afraid of needles
um and I think being around her and her
fear of needles some of that fear might
have like gotten pushed onto me
subconsciously I have no idea is it
because you've seen like Sydney's blood
getting taken a lot where you're just
like oh that thing looks uh I think so
actually yeah because I remember one
time I had to like literally the first
time Sydney going I don't know if I've
ever told this story on the podcast
maybe I have but first time she got ill
um had to take her to the hospital
uh because she had a very very bad fever
um of course uh she had to get blood
taken
um and like I guess like me now if she
gets blood taken she needs not a day she
needs like a [__] week or month
notice to be like I'm building up to
this one moment doctor goes okay we need
to take your blood and uh I had to
literally help the nurses hold her down
while uh while we we take her Jesus
Christ
run away she was that she was like that
afraid of needles you know to be fair
she's gone a lot better now
um but I think I think that one time
when I because normally when I get blood
taken I never look at the blood being
taken and I think that I think having
now helping Sydney every time calm down
whenever she gets her blood taken every
time I see like her blood getting taken
I'm like that looks that doesn't look
natural man something's wrong that was
in her body that was in her body I think
watching someone else get that butt
taken I'm kind of like yeah but then
when I watched it happening to me I'm
like whoa that's weird I love seeing my
blood you're a freak you're a freak I'm
just like look how much it's gushing I
remember because um I uh I had to get
blood tests all the [__] time
um because uh I've I've just got
diagnosed with hemophilia which is a
genetic thing
um not Jessica hereditary yeah
um and I remember they used to tip my
blood all the time and dude to this day
I still want this toy they have this
thing and it was like it was like a like
four cubes by four cubes and they had
like the floating ink in water yeah like
a lava lamp right right more more
viscous yeah and it was just like a
house where like all the ink would just
go around and it would Spin and do stuff
I think I thought that was [__] was so
cool and they would just show it to you
just like
and then they secretly like get all this
Blood get it all it's literally the the
tactic doctors used to want a baby right
where it's like hold on to this teddy
bear I remember I remember I was like
eight and I was like damn this thing is
sick it's like a pharaoh fluid thing or
what yeah like a ferrofluid kind of
thing and just kind of but it would just
go around the house and do a bunch of
obstacles and yeah
I just want that as a thing now it was
cool to look at I was like wow all my
blood's gone
have any of you guys ever needed to take
like any strong like painkillers like
morphine or anything along those
anything on those levels uh no I don't
think so I mean like scope yeah yes you
just cope every morning like like I
don't know I've never had to go to like
the hospital for any kind of like major
injury yeah at least from what I
remember no wisdom teeth getting taken
out or anything like that I still have
all my wisdom teeth uh they came out
straight which is great
um I don't know I don't know I don't
yeah I've never been like I've always
been curious about what it feels like to
get to that state of mind because you
know you sometimes you see videos of
people taking their wisdom teeth out and
they just it looks funny it does look
hilarious at the same time I would be
deathly terrified uh if that ever
happened to me because I have no doubt
that if you boys took me to the get my
wisdom teeth out you just take advantage
of my mental stuff I think you have to
film it like I think of course I I would
like we need to do a trash Case episode
with you just like
to film it and then if it's too cringe
you delete and it's funny oh great we
keep it yeah I think you know it's just
uh it's like uh there's weird videos
just real life yeah
yeah yeah I think the only time I've
seen someone like that happened to
someone was another time I had to take
Sydney to the hospital God so it's just
your experiment so even four cc's of
morph she wasn't she's limit testing
yeah she wasn't giving morphine but she
was given another strong painkiller at
the hospital it was in America yeah and
I remember she was uh she was in pain
and then she wasn't in pain and it was
like oh it's all good and she was very
clear in the mind she was acting like
normal Sydney and then she just goes to
me so God like
serious question
are those walls moving and I'm like no
those walls are not moving yeah when the
wars moved should that doctor give a
shrooms I I
asked like in the most straight voice he
was like no I think those walls are
moving and you are can we can we get out
of this room please
why are the walls wiggling right if you
went back and pushed the wall
you went up to it and then maybe I would
be I would be wiggling yeah yeah yeah
just to [__] with her
yeah I mean it does scare me sometimes
how easy it is to like manipulate the
mind you know [__] was you saying it
that in that Blazer
so like so I heard you want to be
manipulated yes
uh the only um actually I don't know I
don't know the ending to this story
um when I was really young you know
those um those those I don't know what
they are they're like they're like
balloons things but they have weights at
the bottom so you punch it yeah it goes
back down and then it comes right back
up I don't know if I've told the story
before like the punching bag yeah yeah
kind of a punching bag but for kids it's
kind of like you know I don't like this
big and um I was just punch in mine and
I was punching I was having a good time
and then I don't know how this happened
my brother starts screaming he's like ah
I'm like what's wrong he's like your
thumb my thumb is just backwards like
down here yeah
and I I have this memory of looking at
it going
because I'm just like what the [__] but
I couldn't feel anything I remember not
being able to feel it at all did you
like dislocate I think so yeah and I
don't remember I don't know I think I
fainted or passed out and then wait hold
on you dislocated your thumb on a
[__] balloon yeah on a balloon and
then I and then I woke back up and I
remember everything just being okay how
weak are your joints I know right I have
like an 80 year old man's joint sorry I
don't know how that happened I wasn't
just like hit it in some way oh Jesus it
was a funny story my mom my mom loves
telling me that story okay so like
because I've always wondered right like
when when you see like people like
dislocate a joint right yeah I've always
wanted
do you feel that like does it hurt
absolutely right it must do right I
don't know because I feel like I've
been more dislocator the more it can
happen again yeah right and I think the
more that maybe it might not hurt but
more you get used to the sensation right
I feel like I must have dislocated my
shoulder or at least there is some
condition with my shoulder that makes it
like more easy to dislocate because okay
one reason I actually uh have not been
to the gym in a while
was uh was there was there was one
incident and Connor was there oh yeah
and I don't think I've ever talked about
this but uh so you know we were we were
pumping some weights and I believe I was
doing like a shoulder press yeah like
free weights I don't know if that's what
it's called yes yeah we're doing
shoulders yeah we're doing shoulders and
I remember it was like it was like my
last my last rep okay it was like you
know we're doing a few sets of ten and
it was like I was on set nine and Connor
was like come on bro you gotta push it
one more [__] you can do it I'm like all
right bro I got this and I [__] I I push
it and then I like I don't know what
happened but for some reason I just lost
all of the all of the strength on my
left arm right and then okay so I'm
lying down right so you're normally like
kind of holding beneath it yeah yeah so
fast as well yeah yeah so suddenly I
just lost all of the weight on my left
arm and my left arm just goes
yeah like that right and it landed it
landed
this like this close to my dick
and I I was this close to just not
having children because
I don't know if Connor saw if I dropped
it on my leg or my dick but I remember
seeing Connor's face to be like oh my
god did I just see my mate his dick is
gone yeah did I just see my mate lose
his lineage right there like the
bloodline ends here yeah because I I
thought I was like you know you're there
and you're like you're trying to help
hold the weight yeah yeah yeah you can't
do it and you're like oh my God it was
like realize how important it was to to
be better at this because it was so fast
yeah it was like I because normally you
see like shaking and then you kind of
like yeah you kind of grab it but it was
like just boom yeah like that it was
just it was just instant and to this day
I think my my shoulder slightly got
dislocated because I can't it didn't
hurt or anything it just right like all
that happened was just like it just lost
uh all strength fell down and then it
just I could move it again so I'm pretty
sure my shoulder just got disconnect
located
but it feel it felt kind of weird you
know yeah because I've like uh because
I've I've never dislocated anything
myself but I've seen people dislocate
joints but like that I feel the
reactions are always varied like some
people I've seen where it's like I have
no idea like this is like this looks
really painful like you you think they
might have broken something and then
other ones that just like like it's like
it's a slight inconvenience like they
just got a splinter in them because I
remember like one that [__]
traumatized me and and this is like the
day I stopped playing rugby was I was I
was in high school and we were playing
like you know just in in the schoolyard
I think I was like 16 17 something like
that and like it's Australia so like we
love playing rugby and so we're like all
right let's split up into two teams you
know in the year and we had this one kid
in our year called Victor okay
Dutch dude right right we're like 16
years old this guy is 2 meters and 20
centimeters what big boy how is he
allowed to play rugby with the normals
big [__] boy right he's a real bad
you know like 100 plus kilos like built
like a brick [__] house but like 16.
it's 16. bro it's a Becky character yeah
he doesn't belong in your school like
imagine honey I'm a corner without the
scars that's what he looked like right
Jesus but like but but you know everyone
was cool with him because he was like he
was massive but he was a real gentle
giant like you know never heard a flyer
yeah you have to be right so we were
like all right well when you play rugby
you obviously want the British [__]
house in your team yeah so we had him on
our team and we were like well okay
you're the biggest yeah so I was like
all right you're the big boy you can you
can be a forward and uh there was this
other kid uh forgot his name but like he
was you know one of the cocky bastards
in our in our year it was like a little
bit good at rugby and he's like yeah I
can take him on whatever [__] two
minutes 20 who gives a [__] I can take
him on yeah so I remember the other guy
got the ball and he's standing in front
of Victor and Victor's like all right I
gotta I I have to stop I have to stop
him okay
he had a Dutch accent yeah yeah because
he because he like came he immigrated to
Australia right right so he had this
Dash accident he's like oh I have to
stop him okay
and uh and you know you're holding the
ball and the guys hand is out like this
okay you know to try and maybe like push
him out of the way but uh this other guy
was a little bit smaller than the usual
yeah right especially compared to
[__] Mr massive giant over here yeah
so what he does is he runs he thinks
okay I can bulldoze him so he runs
straight towards him with his hand out
like this right and then there's like
this point of impact and then he falls
on his ass drops the ball and everyone's
like oh wow dude you just got absolutely
dunked and everyone starts laughing and
he's like yeah and he lifts his hand up
and his wrist is just completely right
down his hand is down here it's just
completely dislocated but like and
everyone thought oh my God you just got
your wrist snapped like yeah it's broken
but he was just like well I don't feel
anything though so it turns out his
whole wrist just got dislocated but he
was like it doesn't hurt or anything
yeah but I looked at I was just like
yeah you can't look at that
oh and what he did was he just was like
all right yeah I'm gonna go to the
hospital and just walked off if it
doesn't hurt yeah I mean after you
probably get over the shock of it you're
probably like yeah all right well I mean
he's starting to settle in yeah yeah
that's just my life now yeah my hand's
gonna be like this so maybe if it's like
completely dislocated then you lose I
don't know I don't know yeah
it depends on the type of floor depends
on the type depends on the time there's
a lot of variation in there it must be
because like ever since that happened
ever since I almost lost uh my entire
bloodline uh my shoulders never quite
been the same it's like did you ever go
and get that checked out you should
probably go get that changed out dude I
probably should
this is like my friend uh my friend in
my uh high school he
he um playing Cricket obviously if
you've ever played Cricket sorry
Americans or I guess yeah everyone else
yeah unless all the Indian fans like
that it needs Australians British unite
yeah uh yeah I mean you know the ball
goes pretty [__] fast oh yeah and
it's the cricket ball it's like a
baseball but harder it's a cement block
it's it's very you know and and I feel
like making school kids play this
sometimes is a horrible idea
um and he was a very stoic type kind of
kid anyway like he didn't really get
faced by a lot and he was uh very much
into Boy Scouts and all that stuff and
every weekend he's like yeah I just eat
dirt and climb mountains and you know do
extreme sports and I don't know whatever
you know on
um yeah one one time he tried to catch
the cricket ball with his hand and it
went wrong and it only like his finger
kind of clipped it oh but it like
instead of like pushing it back he kind
of like like made his finger here go
like this so it was kind of like [__]
and he was like yeah it really hurts but
I think I'm just gonna leave it and then
he tried to bend it back and like didn't
have much success with it yeah and then
eventually he just left it and after a
few months he was like yeah it's fine
but every time he held up his hand his
finger was like a little bit bent there
and he just left it like that and I
assume I assumed to this day it's still
like that because he just never got it
Like A month's later he never got it
like checked or anything he was just
like that's fine well you know he's like
oh this is my identity now yeah typing
must be a nightmare
or really easy it's like I can reach the
end to keep really easily with my middle
finger now you can reach two keys at
once now you know holy [__] [__] fly
fed Jesus Christ when you forget how to
how easy it is to get injured doing very
mundane things but also Sports as well
yeah but then I guess you also can't I
feel like a lot of the time being like
worrying about getting injured in these
kind of things you know and these freak
accidents like well I mean you still
gotta live your life and do some things
I think I realized recently because you
know you know how this you know when you
reach your 30s you know that's when
that's when you know your body is just
like your free trial has ended yeah we
are going to you know we are going into
the paper
yeah your free trial has ended yeah I
mean that's quite kind of what it feels
like because I wasn't sure you're
smaller you're lighter if you fall or
get hit you know often the impact isn't
as bad yeah falling so like when I went
to Thailand uh this this last time is
like such a [__] minor
minor little thing but it was such a big
I guess wake-up call for me
um as someone now 32. so it's all I did
was I was sitting I was sitting on one
of those plastic chairs that we had uh
that at the wedding
and obviously this plastic chair had
obviously taken a little beating I
didn't know that so I just all that
happened was I sat down plastic chair
broke and I fell on my ass and adults
yeah yeah and there is like concrete
ground on like on like the patio where
on my garden in Thailand so such a such
a minor stupid little thing but like as
soon as it happened I fell down and I
landed a bit awkwardly on my tailbone
and I was like it's fine it's fine don't
worry don't worry it's fine through the
pain it's it's it's it's just all I did
was sit on my ass it's it's it's all
good yeah
um so like one day passes I wake up next
day and it's uh it's it's pretty painful
and I'm like oh do I do I go see your
doctor do I not answer I'll see I'll see
let me let me let me just let me just
hope that it's nothing serious I'm
praying to God
this I I'm not going to get like not a
life life threatening but just like an
injury that an annoying little injury
that's it's really easy to uh I think
break or bruise that bone yeah yeah it
is so it's like different severities
um and so a week passes and still
hurting a little bit
I'm
like bro all I did was just fall on my
ass how am I how is this hurting for a
whole week and then I had to [__]
Google it and then I was like if he fall
on your tailbone what uh what are like
the consequences of that because it
wasn't I'm I wasn't exactly in like
searing pain I don't think it was broken
it was just minor discomfort every
single day and I'm just like I swear to
God if this sticks for me because I sat
on the wrong [__] seat I'm gonna be
so [__] angry at God I so like like
I've been avoiding injuries like my
entire life and all it takes is one
[__] plastic chair yeah and I I can't
believe that chair just gave you a
perma-deeper
my entire life like no broken bones no
major injuries versus one plastic why
does it still hurt now thankfully three
weeks later it is it is three weeks yeah
three weeks later yeah you bruised it
yeah I think I think I bruised it but
three weeks later thankfully now it is
gone but it was such like a wake-up call
to me that at my age just the stupidest
thing can have long lasting consequences
even if it's not something you think of
like a stupid [__] plastic yeah I
mean it's you know it's uh you it's like
like freak accidents that like you don't
know if you just hit something at the
perfect angle where something way worse
Could Happen than it would to anyone
else in the same situation yeah yeah so
I feel like worrying about it it's like
yeah I know worrying about it is uh is
and also hey if it is the chair that
does you in that's how it is man at
least you know one of the 10 people who
die from vending machines a year or
something yeah yeah yeah that feels like
what the hell exactly so three ten
people wait something there's there's x
amount of people die every year to
vending machine there are more people in
Japan who die of getting crushed by a
vending machine than of shark attacks
isn't that [__] up
that kind of makes sense because I feel
like there's way more vending machines I
have more chance of beating up a shark
than another machine
though a build for curry sweat vending
machine I'm done
um it's falling on me yeah my bad yeah I
mean yeah that just makes sense
statistically considering how many like
the vending machine ratio to person
ratio in Japan because yeah versus like
sharks in Japan it made me realize uh
talking about uh that kind of stuff and
like little industries that like I find
that I don't know if I'm I feel this way
but like I feel like because I got hurt
so much as a kid doing sports and dumb
stuff that I I don't know if it's like
perspective or what but like I feel like
when I fall or get hurt and things now
it doesn't I mean it hurts more than
when I was a kid obviously but I'm like
yeah I don't worry about it too much
whereas maybe if uh some of my other
friends try like say uh skiing or
something the first time and they
haven't had that experience of falling
on their ass in a long long time it's
like yeah oh okay yeah this [__] [__]
hurts they take it not as well
um as maybe you would if you've had a
lot more experience falling over I don't
know if that's how it works but it feels
that way like I feel like if you've had
that experience where you've been used
to it a lot yeah especially if it's like
skiing where you're used to falling over
a bunch of snowboarding it's like all
right well it doesn't bother me as much
when it happens when I'm an adult yeah
right but when you see someone doing for
the first time as an adult falling over
like oh my God this is a lot yeah
usually when your first time ever
falling as an adult you're like all
right you're like six foot maybe you're
like 200 pounds that's a lot of weight
further to fall as well yeah yeah well
like I remember like the one one of the
ski trips we went on last year uh most
most Falls I was like completely fine
um one or one or two of them will get
you there yeah yeah yeah and I remember
but I remember there's one four and it
was a pretty bad fall and I fell over
and I was just laying down and it was it
was like I was like it felt like my my
entire body was winded oh yeah that
happens and I knew I knew that I'd like
not that I'd like I'd didn't position my
legs in the right way that I knew I
should have to kind of like make the
fall better so I had this oh [__] moment
where I'm like I know I'm on I know I've
completely [__] up that fall and my
body's still in shock did I do anything
actually serious I think I actually
remember witnessing that ball because it
was on like the last day right yeah yeah
I remember witnessing that fall from
from a dis I was like chilling at the
bottom of the slope and I was chilling
in the cafe with I think Luke and uh and
I was like okay you know seeing all the
boys coming down because I think you
guys went for like another round or
something yeah and I was just chilling
and uh and in the distance I'm like oh
there's gone all right he's coming down
oh he's going a little bit fast and then
you just eat [__] yeah right
and I got worried because you just
didn't move
like it's like usually when you witness
someone falling on a slow break usually
you know they kind of move around they
pick themselves back up immediately like
all right he's good he just fell into
whatever yeah you can just walk it off
but but I knew like something was like
happening because God did this tumble it
wasn't even a fall it was like a tumble
it was like a full flip and you're just
like lying face down in the snow not
moving an edge and I'm like oh my God I
just he's dead like I just I just
witnessed the death and I'm doing it
with a coffee just like watching this
[__] happen yeah and you're on the
ground for like a good like five minutes
or so right like I mean it [__] hurt
but also part of that was just me trying
to psych myself up to be like am I
paralyzed now have I broken any bones I
kind of want to I kind of want to check
but I kind of don't just in case just
like these might be my last moments of
like freedom from any major injuries and
I wanna maybe save this moment and then
I was like all right I can move my legs
thank God yeah I'm good I'm [__] good
Jesus yeah it can't be scary yeah it's
very easy to injure yourself I think
it's easy to forget the skiing and
snowboard and stuff like that are pretty
dangerous oh yeah wow those fun
activities and beer yeah yeah so this
episode is sponsored by expressvpn
gentlemen have any of you broken your
phone before I sure have did it have a
case on it when it broke unfortunately
not well guys going online without
expressvpn is like using a phone without
a protective case look what happened to
them don't be like us use expressvpn
right now because every time you connect
to an uncrypted Network in cafes hotels
airports your online data is not secured
any hacker on the same network can gain
access to and steal your personal data
your data is valuable guys hackers can
make up to one thousand dollars per
person for selling your personal
information online expressvpn creates a
secure encrypted Channel between your
device and the internet hackers can't
steal your sensitive data and it'd take
a hacker with a supercomputer over a
billion years to get brass Express vpns
encryption and best of all it's easy to
use boys just fire up the app and it's
one button to get protected but I have
more than a phone call now what else can
I use it on well like have you gone you
can use it on pretty much anything
phones laptop tablets and more so you
can stay secure on the go gone what do
you like most about expressvpn well
Connor as you know we've been traveling
a lot where they're filming content or
going to different conventions we go to
a lot of public hotspots and I just feel
really secure now that I have expressvpn
on my phone because I don't know what
I'm connecting to sometimes so secure
your online data today by visiting
expressvpn.com trashtaste that's
expresvpn.com trash taste and you can
get an extra three months free
expressvpn.com trash taste get it done
this episode is sponsored by raycons
this time of the year everyone's talking
about making a big change to their
routine but do you actually going
through and do it of course you don't
you need to actually put it into your
routine guys raycon is premium audio for
the perfect price so you can build great
habits without breaking the bank whether
you're looking for a pair of everyday
earbuds low latency gaming headphones or
all speakers with a battery life that
will last all night until your next
party raycon has got you covered sure
you've been going to the gym recently
right I have I used it to run and
honestly I have such a bad habit of
losing other earpods all the time and so
I always have raycon with me because
honestly it's one of the most affordable
headphones you can get and it has
amazing audio quality even if you know
you'll love raycon as much as we do
raycon wants to make sure you feel great
about your purchase they offer buy now
pay later options every purchase has an
easy and free return guarantee and
honestly guys raycon has some really
awesome features for example they have
water and sweat resistance a lot of
noise isolation right absolutely so are
you ready to buy something small with a
big impact go to buy recon.com trash
days today to get 15 off your raycon
order that's by raycon.com trash taste
to score 15 off by raycon.com trash
taste back to the episode well you went
like bungee jumping which sounds pretty
dangerous no body shopping it's fine
it's not like okay you see there's
videos of butter jumping going wrong uh
and you're like oh God but then I feel
like if I'm gonna bungee jump anywhere I
trust the Japan they'd take all the
measures and that they would do it right
I didn't feel it all in danger a bunch
of it was really cool though I really
liked it a lot it is strange because it
was like
uh I've never done it before and I was
really hyped to try it I knew Chris was
very much not hyped to try it in fact he
didn't even want to go near it yeah
um and I I knew I would like it but and
I I in the video it's like all right
okay like I I don't know how to do like
I don't get scared at stuff like that I
don't know why because I just trust that
everything works yeah and if something
goes wrong all right well GG yeah
yeah like but also on the video you have
to like pretend to be a bit more scared
than you are because you know you ham it
up yeah
but there is that like one second window
where you jump out and the bungee jump
hasn't like like uh tensioned yet yeah
you're like whoa you're just in free
fall yeah it's really cool it's like you
kind of in this it's not even a second
it's like less than this it's like half
a second of like holy [__] this is what
it would feel like if you just jumped
off a cliff yeah like just this falling
and the picking up the speed and the
scariest thing is just seeing the floor
get way closer to you really fast yeah
yeah and then and then the bungee you
know it tenses and then you're like okay
all right and then it becomes more like
a ride right right but for that for
those 0.5 seconds where you you jump and
you just see the floor and you're like
whoa that's it that's an amazing you
feel the zero G's all right dude it's
sick yeah it's sick it's so good I get
why people get addicted to it I still
wouldn't want to do it no it's weird
well that's the thing I don't I don't
want to do bungee jumping ever but I
want to try skydiving yeah because it's
like I feel when it gets the sky diving
levels when you jump out of that again I
don't know right this is just all
speculation but I would feel the moment
I jump out of the plane maybe for the
first second or so I'd be like I'm
practically [__] right now I'm
[__] my pants that I've just flown
I've jumped out of this vehicle yeah but
then after a while you just like you
just enjoy the free fall right it's just
like oh I'm good like you know I've got
a parachute I got an instructor probably
like you know and it'll be fine I feel
like I feel like skydiving safer than
bungee jumping though I think I think
the one thing about skydiving that makes
it less scary in my mind is that the
floor from that high up like the ground
doesn't feel real no no because there's
no like perspective it's like computer
generation but I think the thing that
makes bungee's jumping so scary is how
close you get to the ground and also it
just looks like a normal View and you
just jumping yeah like it's like when
you see videos of skydiving you're like
bro this looks like man just jumped out
on like of the Sim City yeah like
looking down yeah I mean like it doesn't
look and I I know that obviously it is
going to be scare in real life but it
doesn't feel like that when you're
watching it I've never tried skydiving I
really want to
um but yeah just I mean that's the way I
I see it yeah and I think um
yeah how close you get to the floor is
definitely terrifying in that place as
well that they had this like swing and
that was way scarier it's a giant swing
and the reason why it's scary is because
you don't get to decide when they drop
you and that's what's terrifying because
it's kind of like you're just sitting
there and then suddenly boom you're
falling right and again it doesn't
tension for about half a second and it
it dude it's terrifying the fact that
you get to decide when you jump and when
you start speeding down yeah it's
definitely a massive factor in what
makes bungee jumping feel more kind of
in control and more fun but the fact
that you can't you can't that's just
anxiety inducing isn't it yeah well yeah
you're sitting there and he's like ready
you're like yeah
this
have you seen those videos of the guy
doing the bungee jumping but he's like
attached to the chair uh no I haven't
seen that okay so there's this video I
saw quite a while ago of this guy um I
think it was on Tick Tock or YouTube
shorts or whatever but it's bungee
jumping but instead of you know you
standing at the edge and then you
jumping whenever you're ready to go yeah
you're you're essentially strapped to a
chair yeah like a regular ass just like
plastic chair and you don't get to go
because you'll it's like a hostage
situation you just attach this chair and
the instructor just like spot and kicks
you off oh
I do love doing the crazy things yeah
ever since I was a kid there like I
always just love that stuff too yeah see
I think that's the reason why I managed
to get go through my entire childhood
without going to the hospital is because
I never looked for that address I've
never broken anything though I I like
you're so lucky bro I think so yeah I've
had some pretty bad Falls and but I've
never broken anything I don't know um
I like my adrenaline as well I just like
it to be controlled because I think the
the difference between five shots of
adrenaline yeah let's let's say the
difference between a roller coaster
Western snowboarding is that I don't
trust myself I trust myself way less
than going on like rails yeah but I
think that's what makes uh snowboarding
more adrenaline inducing it's like
that's it it's it's the risk right it's
the risk there's no risk on a roller
coaster so roller coasters I'm kind of
like so I'm more afraid of a roller
coaster than I am of snowboarding though
why I don't know maybe I'm the opposite
I trust I trust myself more than some
Randolph but the odds of you hurting
yourself is so much higher I know but
maybe I don't think about that yeah
it's the feeling it's the feeling of
like yeah I'm in control of it it's like
it's my body I I have full control of it
whereas if I'm on a roller coaster I'm
like uh you know there's there's lots of
people I can blame if this goes wrong
you know not and none of them are me
I think uh the the bad thing about being
an adrenaline junkie though uh is that
sometimes you have to the voices in your
head are like do it do that it'll be fun
it'll be fun and then you're like God I
should but I might yeah unless I always
love doing uh jumps and on skiing or
snowboarding yeah dude it's like the
easiest way to [__] know yourself
yeah it's so easy to hurt yourself yeah
uh but and you know every time you do a
jump you're like maybe you can go a
little faster next time I think we get a
little higher and every time you do
you're like oh oh I nearly messed up
that Landing that would have been bad
yeah because you know there's a lot of
speed a lot of momentum and you don't
really get to fall nicely on a skew or a
snowball when it's strapped into you no
so uh so far I haven't had an awesome
one in a long time
it's been a hot minute since I really
hurt myself on a skier snowboard I mean
future that's good though yeah yeah
let's keep it that way maybe next time
did you see the Clipper posted of me
doing uh
it was so hard to get it framed though
yeah because in real life you move so
much more than you know obviously you
can anticipate so yeah and one time
Lottery was like I'll be your cameraman
so he's my cameraman while I'm doing the
jumps and of course as he's going to the
jump you know he's he assumes a position
and immediately as I'm I'm about to take
the jump he bends down so you just miss
it and I'm like oh [__] me but it was
cool getting them to do that and get in
the it's it's surreal watching it back
because you you watch the jump and
you're like oh wow that looked way
cooler in my head that it did on the
camera yeah uh potentially get some air
and stream it which I think is pretty
cool I mean there's a reason why games
like SSX tricky are in third person not
first person yeah I think that's true
also it's pretty like sickening it looks
way cooler in third post it most
certainly does yeah it's cool though
being able to do that I think yeah for
sure man I don't know how often I'll do
that it was kind of tough I mean
I think it's amazing that you know like
you said we have gotten to the point
where you can stream something that's so
cool
um but at the same time yeah [__] I
don't need another layer of complex
complexity to add of me like trying to
hurt myself as well that's [__]
terrifying it's like oh I I now I'm in
the trouble of hurting myself and all of
this expensive equipment on my back
I was more worried about the backpack
than me I was like Hey a broken bone can
face
but the equipment nah it takes a while
to replace you know I can I can get a
new leg this equipment's more expensive
than I am yeah you know what I mean
I've been skiing for a while
snowboarding and I was like man I kind
of wish I could have died do something
with it wish I could like stream it turn
into content well just because that's
the YouTuber brain but also I you know I
think sometimes when you get pretty good
at stuff like that it's kind of easy to
be like well it doesn't really you know
didn't really do anything yeah it's kind
of like doesn't do it for me anymore
what happens when you don't have any
hobbies anymore you're like it's true is
there anything left in my life that I
can monetize
that's true that's true this is a lot
believe now it's unoptimized it's a job
there yeah I'm doing it purely for
enjoyment who does that I don't know
it's like it's like a fun thing to
test
um and I just like I like messing with
stuff and I like trying to figure out if
some things work yeah and I always
thought that yeah man this theoretically
there's nothing stopping you from
streaming skiing it's just why it's the
big one and then yeah I tried it and it
kind of worked some some bits didn't
think you can do it again yeah I'd
really love to do uh uh like a a ski
trip for like a one one or two days
probably two days but then like everyone
had a backpack on or like at least
people who were pretty confident they
wouldn't fall over right so maybe not
you yeah
maybe some other competent skiers or
snowboarders who are pretty sure they're
not gonna fall over yeah can can have it
probably Manu right yeah man it would be
good yeah man would be good if you hold
me on some skis I could probably do it
as well yeah right like I think uh it's
easier not to fall if your goal is to
not fall yeah I think if you ski wow
um words of wisdom right there Mr skis
sorry I I mean I'm trying to avoid it
because like if you don't want to fall
just don't fall there is a way to to ski
if you've never done it that is very
safe and it's very hard to [__] up and
fall over unless you pretty much try to
yeah obviously if you're not a beginner
yeah um snowboarding a little less so
um and so I think that you could do it
where you'd be like all right if I have
the bag on I'll be a safe boy nothing
fancy I mean you know during the road
trip right like when we got those shots
of our skiing like Manu was holding a
very expensive camera yeah oh yeah
going very fast but he was he was chill
with it yeah yeah it's a bit too chill I
was like fine for my life in the slope
and he just goes past me backwards
holding a camera I'm like [__] you man
such a flex
nobody's goddamn Europeans that's fun I
I started doing the thing where you just
spin around when I was with the camera
but it just looks like you're just
disorientating people yeah I'm like damn
it doesn't you don't realize like damn
that's that's kind of hard to do it's
kind of hard to show you guys exactly
exactly I guess it's it's fun it was
really interesting it was a cool test
um I I basically saw that Rob did it
that's how I do most of my streams I've
robbed it I was like
I always thought man I should try it but
I just didn't know if you could get a
signal and the answer is you kind of can
yeah we could get signal on the main
slope but the moment we went into like
valleys it just died yeah yeah because
uh when we because I just came back from
Journey Across Japan five yeah and uh
Pete who was with us yeah uh he streamed
like the behind the scenes for like a
couple of days yeah I saw I saw it yeah
it was really really cool and it was
like the most remote parts of Hokkaido
yeah exactly and it's like you know
obviously some parts like the the signal
was dying but it was surprising the
amount of places we actually got
signaled yeah Japan's really [__]
good with signal yeah um if this was in
Wales it wouldn't it couldn't be done
yeah I remember
I remember IRL streaming in Brighton one
of the major cities in the UK and it was
like dropping out left right and center
the moment I got like even like 50 meter
radius of the beach yeah oh I guess okay
Signal's gone can't shoot the beach guys
sorry yeah
it's like I mean obviously by the time
this comes out the my RV thing will be
done fingers crossed it all goes well
and smoothly they'll be really funny if
it went terribly in this age poorly I
better showing great I prepared very
well
um yeah it's like you're already doing
on on location shoots is hard yeah then
when you have to be like okay we want to
shoot on this location
um but we need signal it's like oh
that's so that's a that's a big big
thing to worry about yeah now suddenly
you have to plan everything out about
where you maybe have infrastructure of
the layer you have to like to worry
about yeah but this this it's getting
better and luckily this is probably like
one of the best countries on Earth to
kind of test outdoor shooting and irr
stuff yeah yeah or compared to some uh a
lot of Western countries I mean when I
when I would like go home for example
you know I I would I the first time I
went back to the UK after living in
Japan for like two years I went back and
I was like yeah man it feels good to
just you know get off the plane have 4G
like great yeah cause it's London and it
kind of works yeah then I remember
getting the train to Wales and literally
the moment we got out of like the
greater London area I was like oh I
can't load a YouTube video
oh I remember I got in the habit of
downloading everything because this
happened all the time and I was like I'm
sure I'm sure it'll come back it did not
come back like at all until the train
stopped holy [__] it just did I could I
could maybe get a text in or a message
but like I I couldn't watch anything and
I was like oh this socks like I guess if
you what did people do before
smartphones yeah I guess if you're just
like moving even in a room remotely fast
speed in the UK it doesn't work well
yeah at least where the trains go
through I think the roads are a bit
better because more often than not cell
phone towers are built very closely to
roads yeah
um I I'm assuming I don't really know
why there just is same in Japan all the
because basically how I do a lot of the
deciding of can we film here or can I do
an IRL thing here is I have to go to a
cell phone map Tower right that's open
source and you have to go through all
the mobile networks in Japan and just
look and there'll be like dots of where
they are right yeah but if there's none
nearby it's like well I guess we're not
doing it there yeah because I was about
to say it's like even like in Japan you
could be on the shinkansen traveling at
300 kilometers that's so bad and it's
it's full bars the whole way yeah oh oh
really oh we came recently from Hokkaido
and at least for the first three hours
or two hours there's none it was
shopping from Hokkaido yeah but that's
probably because you're in the long-ass
Tunnel right there was the tunnel and
then you would come out of the tunnel
immediately go in another tunnel go out
of the tunnel going oh yeah yeah yeah
um but yeah I mean normally in Japan
they just they built them all along
roads yeah that's what I've done I don't
know if it's the same and I'm assuming
it's the same the rest of the world but
it was yeah yeah do you remember tedious
stuff do you remember life before
smartphones at all yeah yeah I remember
it and it just it just feels so [__]
so alien to me yeah dude I remember like
when I was like you know 10 11 years old
and you know because it's Australia uh
we still had dial up and uh every time I
would go to my friend's house and I'd be
like yo I found this really funny
animation on Newgrounds we should watch
it and we would sit there for like three
hours as a loaded
and I'd have to and I'd be like uh
excuse me uh uh I need you to get off
the phone right like right now just just
for like the next two hours don't pick
up a phone yeah because I really want to
show my friend this [__] animation
and the animation would last like a
minute and I feel like worth the wait
I I think it's really cool that we were
able to experience such a dramatic shift
in like yeah the human life oh yeah
um something that I guess I mean has
there been anything this significant in
a long time that's changed everything
it's Industrial Revolution yeah
yeah I remember like I remember the
first time
um the first time I had not experience
with an iPhone but like experiencing the
kind of like potential it had uh because
I'd I'd never I'd never been that kid
that would had like the best
Technologies not even close
um so I remember
it was 2000 it was 2008 I was 18. uh and
uh we had heard about some guy this
sounds like an episode of the
in-betweeners we had heard about this
some like a mate of a mate of a mate
yeah who was throwing this massive party
in the middle of a farm
and uh of course we were we were just
like I think you told us about this yeah
I I this is this was like the farm party
where some guy burnt down the couch yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so I don't think I
ever told you the story about how we got
to this place okay okay yeah so so that
that was the party how we got to this
party was okay this is like it was a
farm in the middle of but [__] nowhere
right
um somewhere in like the South down
somewhere and uh I I was a designated
driver so you know didn't drink at that
party or anything I was I was a designer
designated driver because I was the only
one with a driver's license at the time
okay and uh at the time uh didn't you
know the iPhone just got announced at uh
2007. so uh when I got sent the address
I was gonna be I was busy being like
okay I need to actually note down the
route to this address yeah and one of my
mate goes nah we don't need to do that
don't worry I have this new thing it's
an iPhone it's permanently connected to
Google Maps don't worry we can find our
way and I was like you you for real we
can do that the future is now the future
that's the [__] future and he was
like yeah don't worry about this I got
this so he's like he's like directing me
the like he's like directing me the
entire way in Brighton getting how to
get out of the city and stuff I'm like
holy [__] this is the [__] future I
don't [__] I don't believe this yeah
and then as soon as we get just a little
bit out of the city here I'm driving
down the road and then there's a there's
a cross section coming up there's a turn
coming up I either go left or right and
I go uh this this car is like full by
the way but my mate's directing me and I
go uh do I go left or right
doesn't answer I know he goes
do I go left or right uh hold on a
second
um yeah the the cross section is coming
out
uh do I go left or right
uh I don't know
uh it's kind of loading right now uh I
don't think we have any signal so
to put things in perspective uh where
where what we think is about a 15 to 20
minute drive from the place uh where we
are right now there are no Street lamps
there are no lights it is Country Roads
yeah so we we've gone from Full like you
know future Tech to back to the stone
ages okay because we we we have a group
of five people in this car where we know
we're 15 minutes away from this really
banging Farm party that everyone in like
the town is going to
but we don't know how to get there and
so we kind of just choose right
and we uh we drive for about like a
visual mode we are playing a visual
novel we basically just we may we we
basically like we we basically drive
around we waste an hour and a half
driving around every little country road
we can find until we find a road that
resembles the road name of the address
that we're right takes us an entire in
an hour and a half to find we have no
idea where we are we probably thinking
back we probably should have gotten lost
and uh not known how to get that get
back because they're real [__] stupid
teenagers
um but yeah that was simultaneously the
moment I figured out the potential of
smartphones uh and the limitations of
Technology when uh when you don't have
the right infrastructure it just
reminded me of like this memory I had of
in my mom's car when I was growing up in
the in the back of the driver's seat you
know how there's usually like a pocket
for like putting like you know stuff and
I don't think cars today normally have
this yeah but um in this pocket I
remember when I was like really little
there was this book of the entire map of
the Sydney area right and it was just
this giant like [__] encyclopedia
yeah and it's like you'd have to like
flick through being like all right
address
I think
this is like and then now it's just like
yeah it's just all on your phone now
it's so much better I I am completely
content with giving Google uh and
letting it be my overload and having all
my data uh for the convenience that it
gives me yeah I'm like yeah sure just
take all my information dude I I'm not
going back to that I also I I mean I
don't know if you guys feel this way but
I forget so much and I realized how much
I do forget because I I turned this on
and I know people are like why would you
do this you know the thing where I can
like keep track of where you've been
yeah and a lot of people like I don't
want to [__] storing where you've
been and invading your privacy and I'm
like yeah it's fine but like I already
[__] live so [__] publicly anyway
I don't give a [__] yeah I forget so
much and that that thing tell me where
I've been is super helpful for me
figuring out where I was and what I did
on certain days someone's like man when
was the last time we hung out I'm like I
don't know I know oh
dude we went here we went here we
weren't here I remember this night now
like I can't remember it like I can't
remember anything before and then when I
remember where I've been it like all
unlocks the memory stream yeah and it's
so weird because I feel like man is my
brain just holding on to a bunch of
[__] useless memories I can't access
oh definitely unless something like
triggers it open absolutely that's just
unfortunately how memory works is way
better it's way better to have likes if
something is there to jerk your memory
or something then it's way better it's
way more efficient than just trying to
grasp it from yeah like you've ever had
like moments where you've like smelt
something and it like triggers a man
from way back I have that every time I
smell a campfire like every time when
you smell like the smoke of a fire yeah
it just reminds me of like this one
camping trip I went on when I was like
seven years old with my dad and like I
can perfectly Vision everything at that
moment yeah but until I smelt that smoke
it was just completely forgotten in my
head huh and I'm like why is that
that's so weird and it's only with
specific smells as well I don't know why
well it's not just that it's a state of
mind as well yeah I mean have I talked
about this but like if you do something
when you're drunk and then you forget
about it uh
like you'll if you're in that same state
of mind you're more likely to be able to
remember that thing you've forgotten
because it happens all of the [__]
time with Sydney I'm I'm gonna tell you
this right now there is there are a lot
of times where Sydney misplaces a
certain item we look at we like turn the
entire Place upside down looking for
this item that she's lost and every
[__] time next time she's drunk she's
like I remember I put it
and I'm just like get drunk again
quickly yeah all right see they've got
this ball of vodka okay we're gonna find
this thing right now I'm gonna find a
house
man I I feel like I forget things so
much more now than I did like five years
ago I don't know what that if that's a
bad Omen I think it's just because
you're doing more stuff right I think
I'm doing a lot more stuff I've got a
lot more on my plate but like I'm so
forgetful I place things down like I I
have these uh like running headphones I
lose them all the [__] time because
they're like my life yeah I have rice
like and then everyone to start a video
HD I'm like no no
everyone wants to diagnose me with ADHD
every goddamn weed yeah I'm like I I
don't have a hard time focusing I just
forget things
um yeah and it's like I'm like man I
swear I wasn't like this before why am I
forgetting things now I mean it's like a
battle you're like I'm gonna get him old
am I becoming 80 years old am I starting
uh I think I think it's a mixture of
things because we we touched on this
before uh but I do feel the general
attention span of the entire human race
is just getting smaller and smaller
because because of the internet you
mentioned the Netflix thing like a few
podcasts ago and I had this thing
um recently where I was going through
like YouTube shorts and if it even
buffers for like a millisecond I'm like
no
yeah did you
have buffers for just like you see that
spinning wheel for a millisecond yeah
I'm like no I didn't even go to the next
one I just closed the app
I'm like maybe this is the app telling
me that's enough about it maybe you
should go do something productive yeah
either I just turn off the app or I go
to the next video immediately if I see
that yeah yeah holy [__] what is wrong
with my brain right yeah man and it's
like you know it wasn't even like 10 20
years ago where I'd be like oh I have to
wait three hours for this movie yeah
yeah easy no worries I'll just go do
something else yes yeah I just feel like
all this all this technology and stuff
and I was just right now saying this
does feel like there's like weird side
effects that we don't really understand
to a lot of the being being on all the
time and I'm like man I don't know what
it is but it feels like something's
weird yeah we're in this doomsday-esque
situation yeah I don't know why I'm like
I'm sure I'll be right though Google
Maps tells me where I was it's like it's
like do you ever get that thing of like
you know I'm sure this has come with
everyone nowadays but like if you're
like does anyone's dick it doesn't work
yeah you just like take a picture
no it's almost like the water droplet on
the phone meme it's like you hate it
when the water drops on your phone text
all your friends that you're gay
no but it's like you know I'm sure like
you know whenever anyone goes to take a
[__] you're just like all right pulling
out my phone you know they're checking
out some [__] while I take a [__] you
know it's common thing nowadays but like
have you ever had those moments where
you go into the toilet maybe you're
busting for sure and you're prayer
Noggin and you're like all right I've
got no time I've got to run in right now
and you sit down and you realize you've
left your phone in another room and
you're like
[__] what now what do I do I try and
enjoy the [__] that just that just makes
me think yeah I think what did what did
I do before
generally I'm like thinking back because
I had a good 13 14 years of my life
without a mobile phone I must have done
something while I [__] but I can't for
the life of her you might remember what
I did I did yeah I think we used to
think about stuff way more than we do
now because like I think it's really
easy to not have to think about stuff
yeah because you can always just open up
Twitter you can always be consuming
right and it's kind of weird because
then you have those moments where you
are forced to maybe sit there and just
thinking you're like wow this is a
strange sensation that I have to do this
and like yeah that's concerning that's
like a thing right yeah like it's gotten
to the point now where like recently I
can't even shower without a YouTube
video playing in the background now like
I I put on like some audio yeah like I I
know Beth and I was watching a YouTube
video but I'm like that's yeah but even
if it's a share I'm like yeah I got
enough time to like watch a video while
I shower you know maybe like five
showers my last sacred place where I can
think that's why it takes so long in the
shower man
that's my last secret I think honestly
my favorite thing about the Onsen is
that I don't get anything from the
outside world that's true it's like one
hour where all I do is bathe and think
and chill maybe talk to some friends but
yeah a lot of the times it's just me the
bath maybe the sauna and I just I just
think man I just think about what do you
think about life that man stage across
the room I'm like it's like damn it it's
bigger than mine
I don't know it's weird
um yeah it's almost uncomfortable I
think and it's it's concerning
comfortable being by yourself I think
it's strange because like if you're a
kid now maybe you never even have to
think about anything yeah you can just
constantly be consuming or preoccupied
yeah and what does that do to your brain
I have no idea yeah do you ever talk to
your parents uh and they talked about
how they were like when they were
younger back in my day back in my day
how so how so I just like just talking
to my parents and uh you know whenever
they go out to a party with their mates
or whatever and then whenever they're
teenagers and uh they would just tell
their parents okay I'm going hang out
with friends bye and um
no way to contact them yeah and just you
were just as a parent you would just
have to hope
I think is like obviously if that's if
contacting them is never an option and
it's never been an option yeah then it's
something that you're like oh no this is
normal yeah right like and I think that
the moment phones get introduced you're
like oh now I now I can now I can check
because yeah that feeling where you'd be
worried you just convince yourself oh no
this happens all the time yeah right but
now it's like okay you can just message
yeah I know they didn't reply you're
like right [__] off man you start to
freak out yeah right so I think that
we're just really good at adapting to
whatever circumstance we're in and if we
don't have a way of contacting we don't
give a [__] we'll adapt but if we do
yeah and we're like oh God oh God oh God
good I remember I remember my mom
talking about you know early in her life
uh going through some long-distance
relationships and uh having to wait
months that is weird for a physical
letter oh yeah I know I'm just like I
cannot even like fathom that yeah that's
people in the 1800s are like first time
yeah that's strange to me yo someone
just someone just dropped in my DMs man
it's also like you know how maybe you
you go to the Onsen right like you get
naked and that's a completely normal
concept
if but in the western world it's not a
concept anymore but maybe it was at one
point yeah it's like we're just we just
get told things that like this is normal
this is normal behavior yeah and then
we're like oh okay cool cool and we just
adapt like straight up yeah I think I
think humans are just very you know
they're very good at adapting to
situations we're very good at adapting
even to uncomfort and uh yeah yeah even
if a situation is bad uh we're just our
brain is just I think built to just
adapt to it uh just because sometimes it
takes more effort to try and combat it
than to actually just go along with it
yeah and that's why like sometimes when
I am on YouTube shorts and Tick Tock a
lot of times if I feel if I sometimes I
can like
it's almost like I can feel my brain
chemistry changing some some sometimes
and as soon as I feel that like hook I'm
like no this is this is an uncomfortable
feeling I'm gonna stop now yeah
otherwise I'm going to be here for three
hours I think it makes me Dumber
it definitely does it definitely makes
me Dumber like I genuinely feel like I
lose intelligence every day maybe that
should have anything
no I think so as well because okay okay
yeah
I'm okay with that yeah that sounds like
a you probably I don't know what you
guys have been recommended recently like
I don't know why I've been recommended
this [__] recently but I feel like every
other YouTube short or Tick Tock I've
been recommended recently is a [__]
clip from some podcast or something and
they talk about this random historic
facts and then the the evidence you know
that in the Egyptian days they didn't
have ADHD they used to just spank them
into it and it's like and then they just
executed yeah that one Tick Tock music
you know who's that one's like dude
yeah the one over his ears
it's crazy
and it's just like did you know about
this piece of evidence that we uncovered
in like in like the AF uh the uh Amazon
rainforest that no one talks about yeah
Lost Civilization yeah that's all I'm
saying and I know I'm just like why are
these all getting recommended to me
somewhere you know what you got me let's
see the next one I'm like you know what
you know what there is that is pretty
strange that there are pyramids all over
the world and everyone decided to build
them in the same shape oh no wait
how many possible shapes can you arrange
like stone blocks there's like you can
give like a five-year-old Lego he'd
probably be able to build the Great
Pyramids of Giza by himself you know
yeah and it's yeah I don't I don't know
there are a lot of tick-tock holes and
YouTube short holes that you can easily
fall into and I feel like sometimes it
makes you feel smarter while you're
watching it and then you stop it and
you're like I think I actually got
Dumber you're like I've watched so many
Netflix documentaries we've talked about
like a million times on this podcast and
I barely retain any of that information
I don't know why yeah why do I not
retain any information from stuff I
watch I think it's because it's not
significant to your life at that moment
right or or probably for the foreseeable
future right because if it's like you
know if it's something that has to do
directly with like you know your way of
living right say if it's like oh I gotta
learn how to use this new piece of tech
or in the software that actually is
going to help me in the future then
you're going to retain that information
but if it's like oh I watched this uh
documentary on you know Jeffrey Epstein
and why he was a you know horrible
[__] person right then it's like okay
well that's information that's good to
know but it's not integral to my
survival you know yeah I guess so I
don't know like I said through the whole
[__] Epstein documentary and the only
thing I [__] pertained was that he
was a piece of [__]
I saw all the details and I'm like do I
remember any of the details not really
it is weird that's weird I don't know
why we like I I when I see people who
are uh like know everything about a show
they love oh my God I wish that I wish I
had that I wish I I wish I had to retain
any information about half the [__] I
watch I don't know I feel like that
actually loses what do you mean every
like they know everything like when you
hear about people who are like obsessed
with like Star Wars and they can just
tell you every little detail about it
I'm like man yeah but that's probably
their life right like that's that's part
of the thing yeah but I wish I had that
passion to give a [__] to remember
anything I don't even I've watched so
many anime and I feel like half more
than half like two-thirds like I watched
all the chainsaw man and I forgot who
Aki was I was like amazing was like oh
yeah like Aki that character I was like
who's the [__] who the [__] is Aki okay
so he's like the wolf guy I'm like yeah
oh yeah I guess I just remember denji
and makima and power like I I kind of
get that because I um I I think this
just reflects my real life as well I'm
just awful with names I'm so bad I'm so
bad at me like so many I've many people
have meeting up with like three or four
times and I feel like I'm too deep to
ask them for that name again okay but I
don't know it yeah I I'm like like isn't
that bad no no no I'm excited three is
like the magic number right and then
like after three I'm like this is too
much this is too much so many times I've
met a person or I've met someone but
it's like YouTubers right because they
have screen names I know they're screen
names I don't know their real name yeah
I I I have this I'm gonna call myself
out on this but like every time I meet
someone you and maybe like I exchange
lines with them right yeah um you know
how you can like change the names to
whatever on your content all right uh if
I do this thing where just so I don't
forget who they are I put their name and
then in brackets I put in where I met
them
as their contact name so I'd be like if
I met a guy called like Jacob uh in
Osaka right and it was like the first
time in my belly talk to them but we
exchange lines in my line his contact
would be Jason and then in Brackets guy
I met in North Osaka that seems so
inefficient no because it helps me to
remember this is like Memento like
you're chasing the plot to find out no
but then but then because I've had so
many moments where if it was just the
name I and you know maybe we don't
message for a while right and then I
suddenly get a message from Jason like a
couple of months later and I'll be like
who the [__] this guy again I I play
this game every time I have a family
reunion I played this game at my recent
wedding yeah in Thailand
um when I'd hopefully no one's none of
my family's watching this right now but
um I'd be talking to one of my aunts or
one of my cousins or something I haven't
met them in a while and I'd be like
it's even harder because they have Thai
names as well right so my brain is
trained obviously to English names yeah
to Western names because that's the
environment I grew up in
um so I know that I only have a certain
amount of cousins and I've met all of my
cousins and I remember all of the name
of my cousins but sometimes I'm like are
you this name oh are you that name and
I'm like
and and like I I love I love all of my
family and like we have a great time
every time we meet them but this time
especially was like an especially
extended period since I've met a lot of
my extended family
um and some some of my cousins I
actually used to be really close to and
it's because it's just been so long I
remember being at the wedding and uh a
few times like I was like yeah do you
remember do you remember where we when
we did this when we were kids and I was
like [__] that was a good memory and in
my mind I was like [__] what was his
name again is it is it is it this P or
is it that P I was just like I just like
do you remember Paul and it's like uh my
name's Pete
and I was like oh yes of course I knew
that
yeah so I still got to like try and
figure out what I know there's a
probable life hack to be like how do you
ask for someone's name without knowing
you're asking for someone I think it's
impossible I think yeah uh you just have
to bite the bullet and if you think it's
you're gonna get caught out you just got
to be like what's your name yeah yeah
especially if it's just the two of you
then it's impossible but if there's like
a third person in there then you can
just be like please say his name I had
uh I had like dinner with this guy who's
a YouTuber and he was talking about how
he met another YouTuber who doesn't say
their name but he also doesn't say his
name publicly and so he's saying about
how he couldn't remember the guy's name
that he told him one time and I was like
Ah that's so funny meanwhile I was
thinking [__] I don't remember your name
and I thought in my head I'm like I
should just ask now this is a perfect
opportunity yeah I didn't and I
regretted it so much because I still
don't know their name to this day I
still don't and I've hung out with them
three times
yeah it's like but I know that YouTube
name right yeah and I'm like and on
everything I have him on he it's his
real name is not on it right yeah and
I'm like [__] I got it I gotta figure
out at that point I'm just like I'm
sorry to sound like an [__] but yeah
tell me what your name is again
obviously it would be totally fun if I
just say it yeah if I just say I'm a
[__] idiot yeah I forgot your name No
One's Gonna Give a [__] no but also it's
like I don't know in your head for some
reason you think it's gonna always gonna
be worse than it is for you yeah of
course like you kick it down the road
and hope they say it it's like yeah it's
like so bad for me that sometimes I ask
for someone's name and as like they say
it I like oh that's cool and I'll
immediately forget and you just you
immediately just forget it
they literally said that name like five
microseconds ago and you're like I've
already forgotten that yeah I wish I
wish I was [__] as good with names I was
with faces like I feel like I'm so good
with faces like I remember I retain
faces really well but not names yeah I
think that's very common though yeah
yeah I feel because like I I'm so bad
with names but like when I look I would
look at a face of like a photo like in
real life and I'd be like I've
definitely met you before yeah I just
forgot what your name was and what you
do
but I know we've met somewhere I
recognize that face from somewhere
whenever I think I know someone's face
at like a like a fan meet up like if
they've come a few times over however
long yeah I'll always go for it I'm like
have I met you before yeah yeah I'm 90
of the time they're like nope
I'm like I don't think so either no no
then then you can use that to be like
okay because you the one time you do
remember it's they're like yeah yo yeah
so now I'm gonna break everyone's dreams
here I said to her do you remember no I
say you see if I I if I've I've been in
situations like that before with fans
and I like how I [__] kind of get myself
out of it would be like oh because you
look like someone I've met before yeah
no because I feel like I I just got on
the full limb dick on table I'm like
I've met you before yeah and then like
that's a problem you don't you don't you
don't come in as a question because the
payoff is so good like that like I feel
like what because the few times I've
been right I'm not just saying this to
everyone everyone's gonna be like
everyone's gonna start patrolling me
with this the few times I did get it
right they would they would look so
genuinely happy that I was like yeah
yeah but like the think about like the
rate that's like you know being like uh
this next Pokemon move gonna be critical
hit well it's like it's like well it was
just accessories I think as time went on
and obviously the audience grew yeah I
got worse at it of course for the first
few years I was I was so good at this
names not names I returned faces so well
and I remember who I had met for sure
sometimes people like do you remember me
and I was like no they're like oh I
cosplayed this person I'm like
well help me out here you were
cosplaying how am I supposed to remember
you yeah or like the worst is uh
sometimes people come up to you I think
I've said this before because they'll be
like do you remember me we I I tweeted
at you what I'm like yeah my Twitter
name is this and I have this anime
characters my profile picture I'm like
how how would I how would I put that
together
how like I've never seen you I haven't
seen your face I haven't seen your name
and now you come to me in person with a
name and you think I can connect the two
how oh yes Jason uh anime fan247 with
nagator as a profile picture I knew that
yeah obviously yeah you look like uh
yeah
I I remember the best like one of one of
the best saves I've ever done in my life
sure regarding this was uh this this is
all also back in University and I I was
I was at a party
and uh I got along I got along really
well with this guy
um and I was like yeah let's let's hook
up that's like let's like hang out again
uh I'd asked us I'd ask for his name
multiple times in this party you know
this was like this was like three or
four times
um and he goes sure just uh this is this
is like college you know this college
for me so everyone's still using
Facebook he was like sure just add me on
Facebook
yes
yeah I was like so how do you how do you
spell your name again and he goes uh
Dave
I'm like oh [__] he knows he definitely
knows
in this moment they were just like no no
your second name
okay I I still think back to that moment
you know sometimes you get a get like a
memory and I think back to that moment
all the time are you Dave yeah what's
your second name Come On Come On Dave no
no no
oh my God you're right the worst one I
had was um like years ago I I did some
work for like this Japanese gaming
company right and I met like a bunch of
their team right there's like three or
four of them all together right and you
know obviously a lot of like new faces
and stuff and then the head guy I was in
contact with was like okay uh you know
we'll keep working together I'll make a
line group with uh all of us all of them
that you met and I'm like okay sweet you
know because I wasn't gonna go home and
remember these names I'm just straight
yeah but it was so bad because it was me
and these four other Japanese people
three of them have the exact same
surname what what is it like yeah it was
like shuttle and I'm just like which one
was which
which subtle are you because it's just
this subtle song for all of them and I'm
like
you got to help me out here bro like at
least put your picture or like you know
what position you're in like in the
company or something I'm like which
which cycle am I supposed to contact
it's [__] horrible yeah but yeah
going back to what you're saying about
how this this had a really weird [__]
danger but go back to what you're saying
about how there are some people who can
appreciate something by knowing
everything about that particular thing
do you find that to you the more you
learn about something the less you
appreciate it or the more you appreciate
it more I appreciate it really yeah
nearly always I don't know why I just
the more I learn about saying the more I
am I get excited about the small details
and I think that's something I'm really
happy that I suppose I have I didn't
realize yeah I'd be happy for that but
then yeah because it's it's really easy
yeah it's really weird because uh I
thought some people like you that you
know the more they learn about certain
things the more I love it really really
appreciated I love learning yeah because
for me it's like uh for me it's like a
two-way street because in one sense I do
it does help me gain a bigger
appreciation let's say like there's an
anime and I learn about the behind the
scenes about how it was made the
animators that did some certain cuts it
makes me appreciate the art form more
and it makes me appreciate the art form
deeper but at the same time I can never
enjoy this anime in the same way ever
again wow it's it's super weird I kind
of get what wait wait
the magic disappears it's like the it's
like the veil has been uncovered and the
magic just disappears yeah it's yeah
yeah yeah yeah what it's like uh you so
you believe like in your head is it like
this anime is in like some kind of Realm
of magic where it's like I don't know
how it's made it's awesome no no it's
it's like the I guess the best way I can
describe it is
um so there is this very very famous
animator right he's called Yutaka
Nakamura and if you've watched any big
Shonen you have probably seen some of
his work you don't know you've seen his
work but you've seen some of his works
because he has a very distinct animation
style and he animates some of the most
hype scenes in all of anime is he the
guy that does the block yeah the block
explosions yeah so I I had no idea but I
had no idea about it
um about like the old animation scene
and I remember the first time I learned
about this I was like holy [__] this guy
this guy's the goat he's the goat and
he's like he like looked at all his
works I'm like this guy's freaking
amazing and then I remember I was
watching uh one new anime probably like
my hero Academia season two and I was
like super super invested in uh Todoroki
versus that fact was amazing yeah
Todoroki versus Deku that was [__]
incredible I was like immersed and then
in like the most hype moment I saw his
like animation style I saw his cubes and
I it went from holy [__] I'm invested in
this flight scene to oh look it's uh
it's it's a Yutaka Nakamura cup I knew
that and it just like it just took me
out of that moment in that just just
because I knew I've been just because
there was something I recognized and
something I needed like like I said the
veil had been uncovered and I was like
ah it's it's that thing I learned I
think like a good like comparison is
like you know if you're watching like a
magic show right and it's like you're
watching the magic show and you're
seeing this magician do do this trick
and you're like holy [__] like that was
incredible that was a great trick my
mind was blown and then you learned how
the trick was done yeah right and it's
this two-way of like you appreciate now
how much effort these magicians go to
like you know do the trick and and you
know show the illusion but then you can
never see that trick in the same way
again yeah I think I think that's like
kind of the comparison with that if that
makes sense so would this be like a
further question would this be like your
first viewing of that scene or is this
like the second view this would be my
first viewing now that now that I've
recognized the style I guess right I it
it like took me out of the magic because
I know I guess the person behind this
um and so it instead of being invested
in the actual show it just took me out
for a moment just to just because right
now you're thinking about that animator
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
would you feel the same way when you see
an actor you know in another new role
for a TV series or a movie you watch
theoretically it's the same kind of vibe
right it's like if you see Leonardo
DiCaprio in another film you're like
well yeah I'll sling out of the camera I
can't invest myself in this no I I think
I think it's slightly different I think
it's more akin to
because to me to me an actor is a
completely different job like a
completely different right right
um it's it's not in the exactly the same
way with the behind the scenes of how it
was made because to me like the actor is
I guess
he's
he's like a different product in every
movie right and it's their job to invest
me in the character that they're playing
right
um and after I learn about what they go
through with their roles and everything
for some reason that doesn't ruin it for
me yeah
um but sometimes when I when I know I
think it would be more accurate to say
if I know there's a certain director
and I know a director has a certain
style and I really when I was young I
don't know why I like this director I
don't know why I really like Quentin
Tarantino movies for example uh and then
I grow older and I realized oh it's
because of the way he does dialogue or
because like characters are written this
way and as soon as I notice the style or
the pattern yeah and then I see it in
his future works it's kind of like oh I
know the secret to the trick now it's I
I still think you can almost foresee
I still think it's incredible but
there's some magic there that's so
stressed I think it's I think I think it
works with like animation or like you
know uh like magic or like you know
directors and stuff like that because
like the what you're viewing is the art
yeah and not the artist whereas with an
actor the artist is the art yeah right
so it's I think it's this distinction of
like if you know about the artist who is
not at the Forefront of whatever your
view or experiencing then it kind of
creates two different viewpoints that
can distract you from either one if that
makes sense whereas if you're if you're
looking at an actor right because what
because who they are is what you are
seeing it's it's harder to kind of build
that distinction between the two okay I
think another question yeah when you
listen to an anime like you also made in
abyss and then the soundtrack sounds
amazing you're like man I just picture
Kevin
making I do does that does that ruin
your enjoyment or change it in any way
for me when I watch men to be season two
yeah right and you hear Kevin's music in
it yeah it's [__] incredible right it
sounds amazing I'm invested in the story
but then the musician side of me is like
oh yeah I think I know how he made this
and I kind of wanted to and and it
distracts me being like okay so he wrote
the song kind of like this and now all
I'm thinking about is the creation
process that Kevin went through to make
this particular scene and now I am
distracted from actually watching the
episode yeah okay okay yeah not all the
time are you the same then I would say
this is I'm just gonna big up my boy for
a second uh I think Kevin does a really
incredible job at having trying
different different and new things in
all of his works so he he has I I would
say I don't know if he's still
discovering his style but he's doing a
lot of weird [__]
um so what happens is I watch a scene
I'm like totally invested and then I
like snap out and I'm like wait where
the [__] in it that little [__] made
this what the [__] man how the [__] did
he make this that's so weird I guess you
see it that way because when I'm when
I'm watching stuff I just don't I don't
even like I just watch it and I know
that it's maybe this person or something
yeah but I just I just don't think about
it like I'm just I'm just focused on the
show so much that yeah I don't you know
it's like when you hear like I guess a
voice actor you recognize right because
they're so it's not not even the
appearance right it's the voice it's
like oh like yeah I don't I more so I
kind of like seeing how maybe that
person is trying this character or I
like seeing how they do it it's like
ultimately everyone is trying their own
take on something right and I feel like
if you start thinking about it too much
about who's doing what and oh it's their
style oh this is their style oh this is
them trying this I feel like you're so
lost I try not to get distracted but I
think there's a tiny part in the back of
your head that's like conscious that
it's yeah I mean I mean to to say I
don't wanna I don't want my mind to work
like that I'm just saying that is just
how my mind yeah it's it's like like
going back to the Leonardo DiCaprio
thing it's less about Leonardo DiCaprio
but if I kind of I guess learn more
about acting techniques and you know
different more
or something then yes I would be very
distracted in what he's doing on screen
because he's like oh he's doing that I
feel like you'd just be watching it
differently like you're just you know I
would say you're getting distracted it's
like you're watching it in a different
way than I'm watching it yeah yeah you
are you are definitely watching it
differently and I do like I said
appreciate I I appreciate it in a
different way but it's not the same kind
of enjoyment well it's like the
difference between watching a movie and
watching a movie with director's
commentary right like it's it's still
enjoyable but in a completely different
aspect no I don't want to watch
directors commentary really I [__] do
not want to oh I mean I've I've I used
to think that but then I've seen some
like directors commentaries of movies I
really really enjoyed that I've seen
multiple times and and it's like because
I already know the movie and I already
know the subject material yeah watching
the director's commentary of that movie
I know back to front gives me like
another layer of enjoyment yeah where
it's like now I know the inner workings
of this movie and what they were
thinking about with particular scenes
and like that gives me appreciation now
on a completely different level because
the only time I've ever watched
characters commentaries through the
YouTube shorts or Tick Tock
those are the breaking bad ones because
they filter out all the other stuff that
is is boring yeah a lot of the times
there's you know they're not saying
anything or they're talking about
something completely unrelated yeah yeah
all right well I don't care what Mike
the sound guy was talking about like
well that wouldn't be a director yeah
well no because they'll be like no I
don't know it's in like they'll be like
because Andreas commentaries will always
go on tangents yeah like we do yeah yeah
where they talk about something or
something someone else in the set did
that you don't you have no connections
a lot of the times it's not the director
that wants to do this like well we have
a DVD we've got to add something in to
give it a little something yeah of
course can you just watch that movie and
talk over it yeah like okay sure fine
all right if it sells one of the copies
you know so I feel like it's not even
those are so boring a lot of the time
because they just come from a place of
necessity not from a place of actually
like passionate about it like on on like
the flip side though there are some
times where finding out the behind the
scenes can make me appreciate something
that I didn't really appreciate in the
first place yeah [__] uh seeing I was
seeing Avatar Two behind the scenes yeah
I mean it's crazy holy [__] like I'm
it's almost like too much you're like
this seems like way too much effort for
what you got yeah yeah it's it's made me
appreciate Avatar to even [__] I I
actually find the behind the scenes of
Avatar too more interesting how they
made Avatar is way more interesting than
Avatar yeah yeah I mean every time I
talk to Kevin about like you know stuff
he did for me in a personally Tower of
God it's like that just makes me
appreciate that sound even more now yeah
but at the same time the next time I
watch tower of God I'm gonna have the
back of my mind being like Oh okay so
this is what Kevin was talking about
with this particular track you know I
don't want to get distracted with it but
it's gonna be in the back of my head
somewhere I did have a moment [__] would
made into this too actually oh it was it
was
it was I can't remember the exact scene
on the track but I just remember I just
remember uh uh it was one it was one of
the intense scenes in the uh latter half
of made in the best season two there was
this dramatic scene coming on and then
out of nowhere Kevin there's just this
like this synthesizer solo just comes in
and I'm just like for [__] sake Kevin
it's like damn this seemed dramatic but
Kevin killing it on the Sims right now
oh I'm like just like all the flashback
of the Kevin episode just come full
force you just imagine [__] yeah all
those hours of Kevin talking about
synthesizers has led to this moment I'm
like [__] sake he does love this he
does yeah he very much does like I have
a similar experience with YouTubers even
is this just like a me thing like when I
become personal friends with YouTubers
and I mean like and I mean like more
than just like I met you once kind of
thing like when I actually become like
friends friends with people yeah a lot
of the times I can't watch their YouTube
videos anymore
not Cod watch but you can't watch them
in the same way yeah it's a different
different yeah yeah it's and it's like
you know sometimes people are like just
you know that good yeah where you can
still watch their videos and enjoy them
right even if you know them in a
personal level maybe because they just
have that much of a great personality on
on camera yeah but like I've had so many
moments where I'm like you know what I
really hope I don't get to meet this
YouTuber because I really like their
videos
like I'm like that with uh Anthony
fantastic oh yeah I I love that man's
content I hope I never get to meet him
just so I can continue watching needle
drop videos this is the kind of dude if
you said that to him he'd go out of his
way to become friends yeah yeah yeah
please don't despite you yeah because it
sucks because it's like I've had like
so many YouTubers where I'm just like
I've loved your content for years and
I've wanted to meet you and you know and
I met you and you're a great person yeah
and then I try and go and watch their
videos and I'm like
it's just not the same yeah I don't know
what it is it's just a me thing I don't
think it's just you think I feel like
that barrier yeah is just gone like when
you when you know the Creator like like
you you've you've removed that I guess
fourth wall yeah because a parasocial
relationship becomes a social
not for real yeah for real yeah the
power social relation becomes a real
relationship and you're like oh you just
just uh they're just like another just
another dude and I know I know that and
we know that everyone who is making
videos is just another normal person but
when you actually get to know them and
you interact with them pretty often
you're like oh it's just just uh [__]
Chris doing his thing again any
and it sucks because it's like you know
I've I've had the the amazing pleasure
to meet so many [__] awesome creators
you know doing this job but it's just
gotten to the point now where I'm just
like [__] I'm running out of content to
watch bro I can't I can't watch my
friends videos anymore like I have to
constantly be looking for like new
people's content to watch yeah yeah and
it's like and you know again it's like
there are lots of creators where it's
like that their personalities are so
maybe so far removed from the content
that they make where it's like I can
still enjoy their videos as just like a
product but like you know a lot of
YouTubers as well like love putting
their own personalities into them and a
lot of those personalities that they
show on screen are not that different or
not different at all to how they
actually are in real life right yeah so
it's like yeah it becomes this really
weird thing of like it goes from like
watching just this cool person on camera
that you really admire and like this
stuff too so just like this equivalent
of like if of meat from high school just
started making videos right and it's
just like oh this is this is weird I
think it would only happen for me if it
was like the YouTube was uh YouTuber was
a deep character and then you met them
and hung out with them and they were
like just like like chill oh yeah I
don't think it would bother me I mean it
doesn't bother me right right whatever
the video is good the video is good yeah
for sure for sure yeah I don't know I
feel like that's just the me problem
sounds like a you that is definitely a
mean problem it is it is a lost problem
yeah you know when they when they say
don't meet your Heroes it's I'm like I
felt bad man yeah I know it's It's Your
Heroes are YouTubers yeah
even it's it's an even weirder feeling
for me
um like not even like normal videos
where when you have a mate who does
content creation does YouTube and then
they make like a serious video right and
then you watch the serious video
um about them talking about this serious
topic and you're like [__] this feels so
weird right now because I've I've had
like you know deep close conversations
with them
um but right now it kind of feels like
I'm reading into like their personal
diary or something you know I don't know
it's this
eating where I'm like I want to be there
for
there for the fight it's like when you
accidentally find like their private alt
Twitter account you know where it's like
they just like use it as a as a diary
and it's like oh I shouldn't have maybe
I shouldn't have seen this I've never
understood the point of having like alt
Twitter accounts for alt any any of
those accounts yeah and that helps you
have different YouTube channels but
they're very different things yeah yeah
I feel like what what could warrant
having an alternative Twitter account
more shitty memes I post I personally
don't like
I do kind of understand but I personally
don't feel this way but some people just
want to [__] shout things into the
void yeah it just vents into the voids
uh and not have to worry about the you
know repercussions of some of the things
that you get when you post stuff online
you know
um but I feel like
I don't know if you can't say something
online just don't say it online like I
feel like yeah do you need to post like
every thought you have to avoid some
people do some people I don't get that I
don't I don't get that either but you
know some people you just like tell it
like me just [__] sending messages to
the NSA agent watching me like what are
you like I don't get it I mean it's I
feel like it's like when you find
YouTubers or someone they're like oh
they have not Twitter account turns out
they're super racist or something right
why did they do do this yeah she's like
I have a dynamite Obsession just gonna
collect it in my basement it's like what
just what are you doing what I don't
understand is people who have alt
Twitter accounts that are public
yeah right like if you have an old
Twitter account that's like locked for
example then it's like okay they're
probably just using the Twitter account
as like a digital version of a diary
right where they can just like write
down how they were feeling so that they
can look back on it years later right
yeah but I don't understand ones that
are public and I'm like I'm like if you
want to say it that badly just say it on
your own [__] account I don't
understand those Twitter accounts that
feel like they have to post every five
minutes dude yeah and I'm scrolling and
I'm not even on the next day oh my God
I'm like oh boy I'm like how are you
having this many sentient thoughts in an
hour yeah I barely have this many
sentient thoughts in a day man holy [__]
like
yeah if someone does post like eight
tweets an hour on average that is like
the biggest warning sign that's a red
flag that's right I don't interact with
that person
if you start scrolling down and it says
like 40 000 total tweets and I'm like
all right
all right maybe maybe I should have
fallen it's like I understand that
people want like it's hard for me
because I understand people want places
to vent
um and it's like okay maybe I have an
altered account that's private and it's
just for me and my close friends yes
like that makes sense it's like okay I
guess that kind of makes sense but also
in my head I'm like why don't you just
message your friends like I to me it's
plot twist they have no more than two
yeah I'm like I'm like in my head I'm
like bam it's it's like a weird way of
kind of like wanting attention from your
friends without just being direct and
messaging them yeah I'm not really I
don't this could be like a giga L take I
don't know I mean I just like I don't
fully understand it to me it's like if
you have close friends enough to have a
private Twitter shouldn't you just like
hang out with them will message them or
just just those those vents that you
might have why don't you just hang out
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm missing
something giant here I think you are
missing something giant here okay hit me
um uh I guess not everyone has a close
not everyone feels like they have a
close friend that they can properly vent
to you A lot of the time you know
um I think that is a big thing
especially in the age of social media
yeah
um is that you know you can have friends
online but there's a difference between
you know I'm not saying online friends
aren't real friends but what I am saying
is that there are still some people who
you can might not be able to feel
comfortable around showing your true
self
um and it's so much easier online to
mask different sides of yourself yeah
that's it's it's might not be as easy as
just calling up your mates be like yo
let's have a chat right I mean obviously
it's it's it's not always that simple
but I don't know I feel like throwing a
vent into the void that limited people
have access to is also I think it's a
cooling mechanism yeah yeah it's
definitely something a Band-Aid on a
larger problem yeah it definitely is
I want to understand more yeah like I'm
not I'm not like dude you're a [__]
loser if you have an old account I'm
like I don't understand it yeah here's
my my thoughts on why I don't understand
it like if you have one hey you do you
right I can't tell you how to act online
like I'm not your dad you can do
whatever the [__]
this is twitter.com you are allowed to
do whatever the [__] you want you if
you're posting events you're still
posting like in the top one percent of
sane Tweets in my my mind except for
having Twitter blue don't have Twitter
Twitter yeah then we will laugh at you
collectively
I don't know it's it's uh it's sad
because I feel that like a lot of people
who feel like they can't talk to anyone
I'm like [__] man I wish I could wish I
could just be like hey man you'd tell me
you can talk to me man don't worry about
it yeah unfortunately there's too many
people in the world yeah and then and
also did you ever have we ever on those
Discord servers that uh had like vent
sections no have you ever seen these
that's just sounds terrible yeah that
sounds that sounds bad
yeah yeah yeah I mean again the dump of
15 to hit Discord
um they're so they're so bad as well uh
there would be like these like because
you know I used to be on a lot of
servers like way way back
um when Discord first like kind of
started people used to have like a event
section yeah and and some servers well
it's exactly what you think people will
just go invent but then it kind of turns
into like uh who is the biggest problem
and then who can suffer the most and
it's also like I don't think the human
mind is meant to just read stuff like
suffering or anguish or just those
emotions upon those are just going
through them and being like oh this is
these are real problems and like I think
it just does something to your head
where you're like I don't think this is
healthy to to participate in this or
read this but also people who would go
to those were like desperate and it's
kind of like [__]
what the [__] well there's a reason why
you know therapy is a one-on-one session
it's yeah then if therapy is also
expensive yeah right but like there's a
reason why one therapist doesn't take
care of 40 000 people you know yeah
right that's the same time often you
don't have mass therapy therapy all
right let's go on the zoom call all
right everybody put your hand up one by
one let's go through the problem I got
[__] to do yeah it doesn't work like
that of course it turns out I triple
booked so we gotta get through this
it just doesn't look like that and it's
like no but like it it is unfortunate
that like I guess this idea of I guess
like closeness in the digital world and
like social media world has just been so
skewed now so the point where it's like
yeah man I I messaged this person every
single day on Discord play games
whatever but like because there's no
physical connection there yeah yeah it
just immediately doesn't feel as close
even if in their heads they're like yeah
he's my he she is my best friend yeah
but when I actually have a problem that
I need to vent out I just have to take
it to my old account yeah you know it's
it's unfortunate that that's how it is I
feel like venting is a very dangerous
game online
just if you're an influencer or yeah of
course yeah yeah there's been a lot of
Dramas where it's leaked or whatever and
then you're like oh they said what yeah
um you have a private Discord servers
are never probably the eagle Eagle drama
yeah years ago because of this drama
happened where a bunch of uh I guess the
labeled as Eagles
um we're just talking about other people
in there yeah and being very horrible
about it but this is this is pretty
common stuff like these do exist uh I've
never been in one but I've uh heard of
uh them happening before oh yeah yeah I
don't understand how you would feel
comfortable openly venting about other
people in your industry in an open space
I feel like that's like are you dumb
yeah are you are you why like why would
you keep that [__] to yourself yeah why
would you like why would you like leave
that on record as well right like that's
that's what blows but it's insane it's
like the equivalent of going to a pub
right and being like I'm gonna vent to
my mates hold on let me just record this
entire conversation yeah right all right
so uh here's what I had about my boss
yeah what a [__] [__]
we all have bad thoughts right we all
say things maybe in private that you
wouldn't say it openly right because
it's just humans and how we are yeah but
you're supposed to be smart and keep
that [__] to yourself so don't [__]
keep a record of it what are you doing
yeah Jesus it's like um another thing
that I I the main reason I kind of I
don't know how we got on the stuff but
when I meant like a secondary accounts
or alt accounts one of the first things
that came to mind is sometimes uh
streamers or big streamers have like alt
alt accounts yeah to their mainstream
account yeah but there's still life to
anyone right but they're not on the main
account like like the waiting room
accounts all right
um no like the it's actually their
account oh like they'll just be live on
an account with way less followers yeah
but everyone openly knows I I I I I I
think if I remember correctly it sounds
to do with maybe if the audience is too
big on the main they want a smaller
audience where they just play games they
wouldn't maybe wouldn't be considered as
much content as normal right yeah which
makes sense but also in the same way I'm
like that seems kind of odd though yeah
I don't know I I kind of get it so you
still want to play the game but it's not
the game that your main audience wants
to see but also you can just play it
offline where it's available to your
main audience yeah I I yeah I I don't
know well I feel like a lot of streamers
I've met uh why are you saying like that
a lot of stream was like man
um
don't feel comfortable playing games
offline anymore and kind of need an
audience you know I love playing games
on stream but I do gain a little bit off
stream too but it does feel yeah that
feels like a weird a weird workaround to
like get your brain to be like this is
good still right yeah like I think you
need to play games if you are a streamer
I know this is completely unrelatable to
literally everyone
um you know I think that it's okay and
you just need to get okay with the idea
that sometimes
you're not working yes sometimes you can
play that game you're slacking off and
that's okay sometimes you can have fun
like I just yeah I think you just gotta
get over it and be like just get over it
just get over it and be like hey man
some days it's okay to not work yeah
it's okay that's fine totally fine you
know it's it's yeah you've got to have
the you you time yeah you're not
procrastinating you're not lazy you just
gotta give some down time to yourself
you know what I want to know if is if
you do have an ALT account that is
public please explain the reasoning
because I genuinely yeah I I generally
don't understand like I feel like I did
a big outtake but like I just it's not
from a place of judgment or like what
the [__] would you do this it's
curiosity I would like to know how it
helps in any way or how it makes you
feel because to me and where I stand I'm
like I'd just rather not be online than
post that stuff yeah I'd rather just I
don't know I'd rather write a diary and
burn it probably just like talk to my
mom about it or something you know like
I guess not everyone has that yeah right
or I I I I don't know to me I'd rather
just not say that [__] yeah I'd rather
just keep it in
suppress that [__] and then maybe when
I'm like 80 I can tell about all the war
crimes I've committed yes
you know I don't know like to me it's
like I'm chill with keeping that in he's
just he's just lying on you dancing and
being like I leaked those DS
I wish they were infiltrated the group
chat
gear [__] it's like Granddad how
could you what's your statue you're on
your death bed and you got like your
grandson with you and you're like
dig this and it's like a USB stick and
he's like Grandad what's this he's like
it's all the receipts it's all the
receipts
I do like the idea of like right before
you pass away you're like I'm just gonna
cause some chaos yeah I'm gonna just
drop some information I'm going out
swinging
I'm not going down without a fight
yeah if your kids are ever like terrible
people you just make the will like a
battle you're just like you ride it in a
way that causes conflict
we talk about things on the podcast I
always get uncomfortable when none of us
have a differing opinion about some
things I'm like [__]
because I'm like we could be completely
out of touch on this thing right yeah
I'm like what if we're just wrong like I
thought you were gonna say I thought
you're gonna say what if we just like
what if we're falling off we're not
arguing anymore you know also kind of
like agreeing with each other is it
[__] boring when we just all agree
and we none of us have any devil
Advocates to play like no because you
know we still get to have like a
conversation about like how we
collectively feel about it right and
yeah if if we decide to have a
collective L take on it then hey man at
least we're all in it together I'm
having an L take with the boys whenever
I agree with Jerry and God I'm like man
I must be wrong I must be in the wrong
year it's like I'm in danger right now
I bet people on that all accounts are
going to vent about this episode they're
gonna be like why didn't they get me
well well we see it
probably not yeah yeah you know I always
it's always I always like that we get to
talk about certain things that are maybe
more serious or more deep on the podcast
but I always do worry I'm like man with
three guys who we live in our own little
circle yeah and we don't have enough
outside opinions sometimes that's why
it's not nice having guests on there as
well yeah yeah for sure I have the
differing opinions I mean we
I think we're pretty good though
covering bases yeah hopefully hopefully
touch touchwood touchwood yeah I mean I
I like to I like to think that we all
have we all come from different
backgrounds we all have different
opinions and different ways of looking
at the world I think that's what also I
like how I like discussing things with
you guys because when I'm wrong I'm like
they'll tell me right they'll tell me
what if we just leave you swimming the
comments will get him yeah before
like before trash days I didn't realize
how much of my life experiences and
perspective was just based around oh
it's just like a Southeast Asian thing
isn't it what yeah well you re you don't
realize until you get grilled online for
every minute thing you say yeah that oh
[__] maybe I I thought some things that
were just wrong oh it was a me thing
[__] I thought it was an everyone thing
has something that are just me things
I'm like please please be my Heritage
come on come on please stay psych we all
think all the bread tastes the same
right fellow Southeast Asians right
General nobody is born knowing the
correct takes or whatever is deemed the
public opinion on a take and you just
have to learn it and we're gonna [__] up
and and you all [__] up at home probably
you probably just don't realize it
because nobody's grilling you every
goddamn second of the day analyzing your
opinions and what you meant by them well
that's the problem with uh social media
today right is that like there's that
especially with content creators there's
that expectation of like how did he she
not know about this thing that they
clearly weren't raised upon it's like
well [__] me man like it's almost like
I'm leaving a completely different life
to you genuine question
do you think there is kind of like how
can I word this
a rage economy going on for sure in
social media I mean everyone also wants
to have an opinion because in in our day
and age having an opinion on something
is the only currency that we have
socially like you just have to have a
take like that's everyone's thing now
yeah and of course because we've learned
that you want to get as many likes
whatever and we okay we've said this
before on the podcast before but like
it's it's to to have likes in any
direction you go hard in any in one way
or the other right I just feel there's
like there's no winning in a situation
like that uh especially if you have a
social media presence because it's like
in this day and age I feel you not
giving an opinion is still giving an
opinion you know it's that whole idea of
like it's it's like it's like okay so uh
what do you think about this particular
situation that everyone is having an
opinion on and if you don't want to get
involved which you know some people
choose not to that's fine then that
becomes a statement in and of itself why
don't you have an opinion on this and
then when you give an opinion it doesn't
matter which way you go there's going to
be someone angry I mean I do I do kind
of agree that inaction and having no
kind of thoughts on it is also kind of
uh an action in itself yeah because
you've chosen not to get involved and
it's like what does that say about you
yeah if you don't want to get involved
but also it's totally understandable if
you're just fatigued by a lot of stuff
that you're like dude I don't this issue
I don't [__] care about this issue I
have other issues that I'm see that is a
level-headed person's way of thinking
yeah yeah right unfortunately on Twitter
if you genuinely go on twitter.com to
decide how your opinions are formed then
I think you're already going to be
having weird ass thoughts and a really
bizarre and extreme opinions I think I
think it's very important to make your
own mind up yeah absolutely like have
have you guys like noticed um as time's
gone on
um you know we talked about how
attention span has gone shorter because
of the internet have you noticed just in
general because of just some things you
see online you just end up getting like
a bit angrier more often than you used
to just because of some stupid article
or some stupid opinion yeah definitely I
I feel like that like especially in the
last couple of months I feel like every
day I open up [__] Twitter I just I
start off with just rolling my eyes
being like oh [__] what now yeah like
what's the new thing that everyone's
angry about I'm like I'm so sick of this
[__] can I just have a day where I just
go on to Twitter and all I have to worry
about is the next hentai pick I see it's
like can we have that back please like
can people just chill yeah I don't know
because I feel like it's really easy to
get into this like self-destructive Loop
of like oh this thing this thing like
you know there are different tiers of
things because sometimes you just see a
stupid tweet and you're like [__] why am
I getting annoyed so that this tweet has
20 000 likes yeah why why am I
disinvested in someone's dumbass opinion
yeah I just like I I hated that feeling
so I've like I've been trying to go on
Twitter and just you know social media
less but like I kind of realized that I
just I just ended up like it it felt
like one my brain chemistry was changing
because I was getting used to the fact
that I would just be getting emotionally
invested in things that I really
shouldn't be emotionally invested in
general different things that would have
never ever mattered to me in any other
circumstance or any other situation in
my life for some reason now I'm invested
in this one situation right and I don't
know why yeah and I feel like because
it's thrown in your face now right like
there's almost no escape from it unless
you consciously Choose To None I feel
like I have the opposite where I'm I
just kind of disassociate and don't care
for any of these situations right I I
didn't really pay my attention to to a
lot of issues recently people get angry
because it felt so insignificant and so
small um you know and then also when you
see that getting angry has the opposite
affection where it was like oh everyone
getting angry
it completely defeated the point because
they they made everyone angry and then
everyone had an opinion and then it made
it even worse yeah it's like okay so was
was all of that for nothing yeah was all
of that to to for the for your main
argument and main point to just be
undone like it's like why when it seems
that getting angry or getting worked up
about stuff just leads to even worse
consequences
I feel like and it's like it's like
ma'am I feel like we just have to pick
our battles smarter online I just I I
feel like I don't know if I'm usually
going to use the right terms that I I
feel like there is like a subconscious
addiction to it I love it I think people
love getting angry I I feel like with
the way with the way the internet's gone
I feel like subconsciously people are
looking not like maybe not like
consciously looking but subconsciously
it's it's like whenever there's
something they can
grab onto to get angry about or like to
like look at this thing and be like look
how dumb this thing is online yeah
um I don't there's there's this
subconscious thing in your brain that
goes yes you should you should get
involved in this you should have an
opinion on this one way or the other and
I feel I feel like the internet and
social media has trained our brains to
to do that yeah yeah I don't like maybe
this is just me growing up my generation
but I don't know if this is the way
things worked in previous generations
you know people would just let people I
mean I think the way it used to be and
the way it kind of I I think I
appreciate more and more is that you
kind of just pick the battles you're
passionate about yeah cause that speaks
to you yeah maybe for whatever reason
that is and I still try and do that you
know obviously if there's if you're I
think there's a difference between
um supporting an argument and actively
getting involved in it yeah uh you know
and I think that's that's a really
important distinction to make and
something that gets lost a lot where I
think a lot of people perceive inaction
as a lack of uh kind of support in any
way where it's like well I in some way I
kind of disagree where it's like if if
you on on like say on online or
something like let's say
I don't know how to how to word this
correctly uh without getting my whole
entire career destroyed
like it's it's like if you're not
actively doing stuff to
um
like further a cause or you're not
trying to like raise money or spread
awareness does that mean that you don't
support something and it's like I don't
I don't think that means you don't
support it I think it just means that
maybe that's one of the things that you
didn't choose to spend your energy on
yeah there's only so many battles you
can take like at the end of the day
you've got to go to work you've got to
go to school you got to do [__] and you
can't go home every single day and be
like all right what's the new thing
what's the new battle what am I what am
I uh what am I getting passionate about
today it's like I feel that as human
beings we just we were just meant to
survive and then maybe if you have the
time and if something is really
passionate maybe it affects you directly
or maybe affects a loved one then maybe
you get more involved with it and I
think it's like expecting everyone else
to feel as passionately as you do 24 7.
causes a lot of friction like and I
think it's it's that kind of stuff
that's frustrating and it leads to
people who maybe are in support of stuff
to get really frustrated and really
tired because other people who support
it but way more passionately like why
aren't you doing as much as me why
aren't you saying as much yeah yeah and
I think that's a really that's been a
really uh tough thing to deal with
because on the internet now it's so much
more accessible and so much more uh so
much more uh so much easier to to say
those thoughts to someone and I I feel
like a big thing is that I don't know if
I explained that even that could have
been gibberish yeah I don't know that
made sense because I I feel like a big
thing is that it's never been easier to
feel like you can be involved you can
make a difference in something even if
doing a tweet or doing a Facebook post
is like the the entirety of what you can
do you still feel like you're
contributing in some minute way to
something and I feel like that feeling
of
that that emotion of feeling like you
can have an effect direct effect on
something or someone has just caused
this kind of environment yeah uh because
okay
Theory Theory okay
I feel like I feel like there is a
reason why they're like
a video trend has gotten really popular
recently and it's the video trend of how
X YouTuber fell from fame or how this
person Fell From Grace right or how this
person right I I don't like those videos
too much but I will admit I'm [__]
addicted to them okay there is something
about those videos where I'm like I
shouldn't watch this but my something my
brain's like you should
even if the presentation is terrible
even if the quality video is so bad I
think the information in it is quite
valuable in a weird way
in a way that just kind of hacks your
brain but I but it's but it's so crappy
these types of videos are the True Crime
for YouTubers like like we are the white
girls and those are the True Crimes I
agree I agree because okay you're right
you know you know what I'm saying
because like I feel like okay very I I
feel there is a subconscious part of
your brain that is like I want to feel
it's I want to feel better than someone
today I want to feel like my life is
going better than someone else's today
and there's a part of you that's like
preparing for the worst yeah yeah it's
like learning by example and there's a
party that's like prepared okay this is
what I need to not do to [__] up yeah
and so even though there is probably
nothing in those videos that or like
maybe one video will be useful but like
watching 15 of those videos there's you
know you can't really guard anything
just while those 15 videos you know the
story there's some Minecraft Youtuber
they gross the fame really quickly and
then they fell off okay we know the
[__] story yeah
um but there is there is some part of
your brain that I think you watch those
videos because you are kind of
everyone's going through some hard
things in life and we want to know how
to make our lives better and you know
even though it's not a pleasant thing
sometimes seeing someone fall yeah make
yourself feel better yeah
that feeling of like ah what's it mean
yeah yeah yeah I don't know why we would
like this yeah I don't know why I would
like this but there is somebody who does
like oh I'm so glad that wasn't me yeah
and you know it's it sucks it sucks
because it could be us it could be us
but you're like you and I I know that
but some part of me is like
no I totally get that like you could be
like the most like wholesome supportive
nice person that's like you know
open-hearted to like every person every
difference and everything but like you
know sometimes yeah like negativity or
viewing negativity sometimes reinforces
self-positivity and it's like that's
just how we are as people unfortunately
yeah one one thing that I uh I had a I
had thought about and I don't know why
it stuck with me a lot
um uh there was this um this was a
charity event where uh you know some
celebrities had gotten involved and um
like big big celebrities yeah and um I
was having a conversation with someone
who uh was working for the charity and
they were talking about oh how they
invited this other celebrity but they
said no because they're doing uh another
charity or something uh and I was like
oh that's weird why wouldn't they want
to like help both and they were like oh
well it's like in that in that sense
it's like you you have to pick your
battles like if you use only so many
times that you can ask
um the audience or the people who are
paying attention to you to give money to
a course yeah because you you know
you've got a few ask them one time then
you ask them again a week later you're
like all right well well dude I just
gave money like what do you you know
pick the battle here like pick the right
course and maybe think of like how it is
how I could extrapolate that kind of
thought to social media and how I how
people treat that in general it's like
yeah people got to pick their battles as
well like you you can't always be there
for everything yeah people you know
people have to pick whatever personal
priority they decide to pick right I
feel it's very unfair to like criticize
that unless it's for like a really
really just like objectively unethical
reason right yeah but you know in the
case with like your example right it's
like well [__] I mean it's easier said
than done if if everyone had the
mentality of right of like oh I could
just do both or I could just do all of
these then we wouldn't need charities in
the first place you know like everyone
would just be well off all right yeah
everyone would just be giving money to
one another but unfortunately that it
doesn't work like that like you you have
to at the end of the day some people
sometimes just have to prioritize what
they need to prioritize and those
priorities might be different from the
next person yeah but that's that's
that's just how they are like you can't
I feel it's very unfair to like push
your own self-priorities onto someone
else especially if they live in you know
completely different circumstances or
completely different lives right it's
like yeah it's it's I don't know I've
I've that that's always irked me and
especially when it comes to like you
know having an opinion online about
anything right it's like you know maybe
their priority is to not get involved
yeah like that's that doesn't mean
they're any less of a person just
because they're not getting involved
that's just their priority and
unfortunately there's nothing you can
really do or say to like change that I
guess yeah I don't know it's it's it's
tough I I don't know what I'm saying
you have a lot of thoughts that feel
cohesive but explaining them is so tough
yeah yeah yeah it is it is
um and I'm just I know that a lot of
people come to the podcast because we
don't talk about a lot of political
issues I think it's also because we're
[__] terrible at talking about that
yeah uh we can barely talk about our
opinions on food yeah video games and
I'm like uh I'm gonna make the conscious
decision to not talk about this because
I do not trust my own self to articulate
yeah a problem
let alone here let alone a serious
problem I'm not articulating that in any
way there's people who can do it much
better than we do that's for sure yeah
it's tough it's tough the world feels
really rough right now yeah I think it's
hard to to stay positive and not get
angry about stuff I mean there's a lot
of stuff that is worth getting angry
about right now yes
um so yeah pick your battles pick your
battles hopefully uh hopefully things
change for the better and hopefully
you're not watching uh how trash taste
fell off uh in another three years it'll
probably happen at some point
everything's gonna fall off
I just hope it's well edited yeah if it
does happen yeah you know make it look
nice at least
but hey look at all these patrons though
wow so many of them they made a
conscious decision to support us oh and
that I think is a great thing to do and
hey if you'd like to join us and support
us as well then make sure to go to our
patreon patreon.com trash taste also
follow us on Twitter send us to memes on
the subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on Spotify and uh yeah we
will go back to talking about poop and
food yeah food tomorrow yeah the poo poo
pee jokes are coming back hentai episode
next week yeah hell yeah all right we'll
see you guys next week bye
[Music]
thank you